[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
KRISTI LEWIS: So
today, I'm really
excited to have you here to
talk a little bit, not just
about the coffee, but
your path to getting
to where you have today,
to talk to you guys,
and to see how Colby has been
able to successfully live
a life of work-life
balance doing things
that he's passionate about,
and really just having an idea
and going for it.
So maybe we just
start out talking
about how you decided
that you wanted
to get into the business.
COLBY BARR: Sure.
Thank you guys for all coming.
It's pretty awesome to
be here in San Francisco
at Google serving
coffee to you all.
Google is-- I'll totally
get to what you said.
KRISTI LEWIS: That's good.
COLBY BARR: Yeah, Google was
actually one of our first,
back in the day,
clients, actually,
that we ever sold coffee to--
kind of a more big league
client, out of Santa Cruz.
One the first people we sold
to was on the original Google
campus.
And our 1950 blend,
in fact, that we
sell-- one of our most
popular selling blends--
was named after the
1950 building at Google.
So big ups.
But it's our trademark so--
just kidding.
But so, yeah, I mean, I grew
up, not really, I guess,
in the Bay Area, but
in the couple of hours
north of San
Francisco in an area--
Napa, Mendocino, Lake
County, Sonoma County.
Family is from
Sonoma County, and I
grew up there farming
pears and wine grapes,
and in the old kind of
classic farming family.
And work hard, and then play
hard, but mostly work hard.
And you know, my dad went to UC
Davis-- did that whole thing.
And so it was really
instilled in early life
about really caring about food
and produce, where things come
from, and also
seeing really early
on how there are a lot
of people out there
doing amazing work in food.
And they're very
rarely recognized,
or even less rewarded for that.
And so that was kind of always
on my mind in this back burner,
which I guess we
can circle back to.
But it definitely
instilled to me
these core values that
there's something out
there that exists for
doing great work and food,
and that there was
an opportunity there,
but that more was a
revelation I had later.
But what kind of really
kicked me into just getting
into coffee is the cliché reason
most people get into coffee,
which is you go to college.
You go to coffee shops.
You hang out.
They're cool.
You try to order cool drinks.
You usually don't.
You know, my gateway to
coffee was drinking mochas
that I hated.
I loved everything about it
except for the espresso taste.
When I was in high school,
trying to go play--
I used to play jazz, and
going and playing jazz combos,
and going to coffee shops,
and just sort of being
enamored with this coffeehouse
vibe-- this coffeehouse
culture.
Then you go to college.
And then you end up studying
there and hang out there.
And you find the cool one.
And you go to the
one that's cool,
and not the other ones
because it's not cool.
And just kind of always in
the back of my mind thought,
clichély, coffee is cool.
And wouldn't it be cool some
day to do something in coffee?
More in the back of the mind--
I went and did other things, and
studied environmental science.
And I did GIS, and did
that for like five years,
and did a lot of computer stuff.
And then wanted to really
do something on my own,
which I guess may be coming
back to that basis of growing up
on a family farm.
When you're in a
family that farms,
you don't clock in for work.
It just is life.
So I always just thought
I'd work for myself.
And then after five
years of not doing that--
I kind of did.
I was like a contractor.
But I really wanted to
just start my own business.
And so--
KRISTI LEWIS: And this was while
you were in school, in college.
COLBY BARR: This was right
after I finished college,
but I still lived
in a college town
up north, Chico, where I ended
up living, and going to school,
and other things.
KRISTI LEWIS: We can get
back to those other things.
COLBY BARR: Yeah,
yeah it was cool,
learned a lot about myself.
Yeah, no, it was great though.
It was perfect.
It was the path I was
supposed to be on.
But yeah, getting into wanting
to start my own business,
and, ultimately,
taking that leap.
But when I thought, well, what
is the business I want to do?
I came back to this
thought that had always
been incubating in
the back of my mind
that well, coffee is cool.
Coffee shops are cool.
I loved music.
And I just loved this--
what I thought, at that
time, had a very direct tie
to coffeehouses.
I collect vinyl,
played in bands,
only played analog
instruments, and, somehow,
coffee fit in the same strata
as those elements of my life.
And so without a ton--
without any
experience, but I went
to talk to the guy in the
cool coffee shop in town
to ask him, would you mind--
what does it take to do this?
How do I be great?
What does great look like?
Which was an
important lesson, I've
tried to always carry
with me moving forward.
And he said, actually,
I'm thinking about selling
this coffee house.
Are you interested in buying it?
One thing led to another,
and three months later, I
was standing in the coffee shop
that I owned with not exactly
understanding what to do,
understaffed, and, really,
had to just feel the weight
of it all, of what it's
like to take that risk, that
commitment, and just say,
screw it.
Let's do this.
KRISTI LEWIS: So do you feel
that it was an out of comfort
zone type thing, where you're
like, I'm in a coffee shop,
and somebody is
presenting this to me.
And I hadn't planned on it, but
now here this opportunity is.
Was it an easy decision
for you to just
say, Yep, I'm going to do it.
Or you know, how did you
feel going into that?
COLBY BARR: I don't know
if it was an easy decision,
but I kind of have
a point of view
on these things, which is
that decisions are hard,
so sometimes it's best
just to corner yourself.
You know, burn your bridge,
or whatever you want to say.
But I make the
commitment before--
I'm all about analysis.
I was an analyst for five years.
So I'm all about
analysis and research
is my favorite thing to do in
life, probably, one of them.
But at some point you just
jump, and you won't ever
have all the information.
And I do believe a saying
that once came to me.
My sister who is up
here can bear witness.
The classic place where you
gather all life information
to make important decisions,
which is after a Prince concert
at a blackjack table at
like 2:00 in the morning.
But I ended up
talking to someone
who worked in
technology, and, I guess,
had built a pretty
successful company.
And we ended up talking
for a long time.
And I just said, if you
could give some piece advice
to a young person who's wanting
to really do something special,
and, really, get to, maybe,
in a position like you're in.
Not necessarily like--
I don't know if he was wealthy.
I'm pretty sure he might
have been, but just more--
I could just tell that he
had gotten to some place
that he felt very
satisfied with.
And he just, without
even blinking,
just looked right
at me and said,
take chances and
overextend yourself.
And that's sort of been
my go to since that night.
And, in a way, it's
this permission
that some dude at a blackjack
table after a Prince concert
gave me.
So, of course, it's valid
and totally trustworthy.
KRISTI LEWIS: I feel like
those little things come
into your life at just
different times that
reinforce that you
are on the right path
and doing the right thing.
I mean, here you are now,
co-founder of a global company,
right?
COLBY BARR: Yeah.
KRISTI LEWIS: Yeah,
so that's awesome.
COLBY BARR: Yeah, and
I think, too, I mean,
to answer a question,
the decision--
it wasn't easy but just feeling
like I had this permission
to make it, and
then just jumping--
choosing to jump,
instead of choosing to,
let's just wait a
little bit more.
I'm more of a jumper,
for better or worse.
But I think there is something
to that that, you know,
in life you have to
make a lot of choices.
And so I think getting
comfortable with making
choices, or becoming decisive
knowing you're, for sure,
not going to be right.
Was it the best decision I
could have made in my life?
I'll never know.
But it was the one I
made, and it got me here.
It was a stepping stone.
So it was definitely
a critical decision,
which then led me to
my next decision, which
was to start Verve with
my business partner Ryan
who's over here.
Hi, Ryan.
RYAN O'DONOVAN: Hi.
COLBY BARR: He doesn't
like being outed, but--
KRISTI LEWIS: So you
had your store in Chico,
or your shop in Chico,
and what was the path then
to opening up your own brand?
COLBY BARR: Well,
one year into it,
after being super understaffed.
And you learn a lot when you
don't have anyone you can--
when you know that
there's no one else's
responsibility but yours.
There's no like that--
there's no boss.
You look for it, and you
realize, shit, I'm it.
And you just, OK, now
what am I going to do?
And you have to make calls--
a lot of bad decisions,
a lot of great decisions,
but decisions nonetheless
that move you forward--
and learning a lot about having
the right people on the bus,
and learning what it's like to
have wrong people on the bus,
and have to fire people,
and do all these things.
It was my first
year in business.
But what came through
it-- besides the business
parts, and sales tax, and all
these bookkeeping things that
are not my big passion,
but are super important,
if you want to run a business.
Do not think they're
not important.
Hire an accountant before
you hire anybody else--
was how much I was falling
in love with coffee.
Because when I got into
coffee, it wasn't for coffee.
It was for coffee house culture.
But after one year into
it, spending every day
doing it, becoming a
barista, just, and connecting
with a couple of people--
a friend Sean White,
who now does Flat White.
He's a ceramicist for a
lot of coffee shops around.
He was our first
employee at Verve--
a few other people, and
dropping into the world that
became barista culture,
third wave coffee,
I became completely
enamored with coffee itself.
And as an analyst,
and a researcher,
this trap door opened.
And I fell through it.
And it was the universe of just,
where does coffee come from?
Why are some coffees taste
different than others?
What's happening?
What's up with roasting?
What are different origins?
What's up with
different varieties?
I have to know everything
about all of this.
And I was thinking about how
do I learn-- how do I jump in?
Because I just had
this coffee shop,
and I thought about my friend
from college who I played music
with, who had been in
coffee his whole life,
and was a home roaster, and
was the biggest coffee guy
I knew, Ryan O'Donovan,
my business partner.
And we started--
I called him one day just
from a park bench in front
of a farmers market,
and said, dude
we should start a coffee
roasting company together.
He had just moved
back from Portland,
working at coffee shops--
coffee shops, coffee roasters,
wholesale, everything.
And, long story
short, we just met up
a few days later, started
looking for spots,
and within a couple of
months, we signed a lease
and started Verve.
KRISTI LEWIS: In Santa Cruz.
COLBY BARR: Yes, in Santa Cruz.
We almost-- we originally
had opened in San Francisco.
And at this time--
2005, we opened-- the
only third wave coffee
company in all of California
was Ritual on Valencia.
In all of Cali-- and
they carried Stumptown,
and that was it for
the whole state.
So at this point in time if you
opened a cool company anywhere,
people everywhere knew about it.
We were going to open
in San Francisco,
then almost opened in
Berkeley, Berkeley Oakland.
At the last minute,
right before we
were supposed to sign the
lease, I got a call from Ryan.
He just said, dude, I'm
moving to Santa Cruz
because I got my lady.
We're probably going to
get married some day--
which he did, and they
have two awesome kids--
and said, this is the
lifestyle I want to have.
I want to able to surf.
I want to be able to
ride mountain bikes.
I want to build a company
where I want to be.
And so it kind of fell
apart for like a week or so.
And then I kind of
thought, well, let's just
go look at Santa Cruz.
And one thing led
to another, and we
ended up making the
commitment there, and said,
well, let's see if we can make
noise even though we're here,
which we didn't think
we'd be able to do,
but, fortunately, we
were able to do that.
KRISTI LEWIS: That's awesome.
So, basically, it goes to the
idea of work-life balance,
and choosing a location
that can adapt to the things
that you want to do in
life, where you can pursue
this passion that you
have, a dream that you
have that you want
to achieve, but also
to be able to maintain
like, I want to go surfing.
I want to go mountain
biking and whatnot.
So can you talk a little
bit more about that,
and how you're able
to achieve that.
COLBY BARR: It's
a great question.
KRISTI LEWIS: You're right.
COLBY BARR: It was definitely
in the ethos of starting
our company as I described.
But I think, fast forwarding
to present day, it's hard,
you know?
I mean, it requires you saying
that you want to do that.
And then, I mean,
work-life balance--
I've heard work-life harmony.
Bezos talks about that.
And I think it's
interesting to think
about it because it's really
dependent on the individual--
where they're at in their life,
their age, what they want,
and what's energizing them--
to determine is
that a light switch?
Is it a yin and
yang, and they have
to be opposites, and that's
how they are distinct,
but also fuel each other.
How you-- or is it a fader?
I think of the harmony as
multiple things at once,
but it's like C major, or
maybe it's like D minor
depending on your mood.
I love D minor.
But I think it takes practice.
And, again, it's different
for different people.
I mean, one thing, for sure,
as an exercise is just-- again,
I like cornering myself--
so is to force
yourself into doing
something, where you,
for sure, can only be
thinking about that one thing.
So whether that's-- a lot
of people have sports,
like surfing or mountain biking,
getting into your flow state,
which I know can happen on
computers in a lot different
ways I've experienced.
But if you take it
into outside of work,
and you can pick up an activity,
or an exercise, or something,
or yoga, float tanks.
I don't know, whatever
it is for people.
I like all that.
But that you just have
to be in that moment
because it requires
all of your attention,
and that's one way to break.
Whether it's you always
have two days off in a row,
or every year you take off for
a few weeks to go do something.
So there's a lot of
different ways to do that.
But I like trying
to figure out--
find activities that
require all your attention.
KRISTI LEWIS: That
definitely makes sense.
I think that just, in
general, the culture here
is, or not here as in
Google, but here as
in the US is that it's
very work-focused,
and to be on the clock all
the time, and to make sure
you're doing everything
all the time.
But there's something to
be said about breaking that
up, and doing the
things that you love,
making work even
something that you love,
and making sure you are
in that right headspace.
And I admire the
fact that you're
able to go to so many different
activities, and focus on them,
and the drive that you
have is really amazing,
so just going to call that out.
COLBY BARR: But
I think, you were
saying about
enjoying what you do,
to me that's a big part of it.
I mean, that's why I
started my own company.
But I used to do all
of our orientations
for like, six years.
Every single employee
that ever worked at Verve.
I did every employee's
orientation.
I used to just tell
people like, we want
people that want to be here.
And if you don't want to be
here, I want you to quit.
KRISTI LEWIS: Which
is hard, right?
COLBY BARR: And not meaning
like, because we're so cool,
and like, you don't belong.
But no, just like,
I will help you
find a-- put in
notice, whatever, I'll
help you find a different job.
But you owe it to
yourself to do something
you're passionate
about, whether it's
starting your own business,
or not because people
are energized in different ways,
or being part of a team that
has a huge lever for
change, like Google,
or how you get empowered
in your own way.
But the one thing that kind of--
the work-life
balance, when I feel
like it's this dichotomy
that I don't like
is the feeling that you
would just do something
that you-- that
it could mean, you
put up with something
that you don't love
to do, or even like
to do, But you only
have to do it eight hours a day.
And then you get to live
your life, which is cool.
I mean, a lot of
the best musicians
I've known in the world had
day jobs that were whatever.
But I do think it is
important to just find
what you're passionate
about, or find
how to be passionate in
what you do because it just
makes everything better.
And, to me, a little bit,
that's the harmony part,
which is that your work should
be part of what fulfills you.
KRISTI LEWIS: And I think
that that shows in your shops
as well.
I've been to a few of them,
and the staff is very friendly.
They all do their
job really well,
and they seem to actually
enjoy being there.
So maybe you could talk about
how you incorporate that
into your company culture.
Asides from telling
them that they can quit,
if they don't really
want to be there.
COLBY BARR: Yeah, I want to
tell people they have to quit,
if they don't want
to be here because I
think that's what people
should do for themselves.
But it is something
that's probably
been the most difficult
thing as we have scaled.
Because when you have one
shop, or the small team--
I forget the number
of people talk
about for a small tribe,
10, 15, 30 people,
but once you exceed that--
there is a lot that happens
innately, especially when you
have the small group.
Leaders are present.
This trickle down
effect, it's just
very obvious to
everyone what that--
it's easier to set
expectations without having
things so explicitly written.
But as you scale, 40, 50,
80, 100, 200 employees
we have at Verve now.
I don't how many
employees Google has,
but I'm sure it's more than 200.
It's probably about
200 in this room.
But it's the hardest thing
to do is to scale culture
because at a certain point, you
have to literally be thinking,
how am I engineering
culture now?
And it feels--
there's a falseness,
if that's a word, that
comes with that idea
that you're engineering culture.
But I became enamored with it
a little bit because, well,
you're just trying to--
it's a point about being
reflective and self-aware
as a brand and as a
company, and to figure out
how you want to
communicate that,
and to build that
into the culture,
to set those expectations,
and then, ultimately,
have the right
people on the bus.
I mean, I'm a big fan of--
I know, maybe, it's old school
now, but "Good to Great."
Jim Collins getting the
right people on the bus.
There's no substitute for that.
You cannot train
somebody into getting it.
You have to just get
the right people,
and then figure out
how to empower them.
And that's what
we've done Verve.
And that's what I
think we're really
focused on this next
year and beyond,
is to really figure out
how to build a framework,
so that people really
feel empowered, and can
channel their own
entrepreneurial spirit in what
they do.
And that's a little
bit of, I think,
what you experience when
you come in to Verve,
and you have people
smile and greet at you.
We've been criticized
for being too friendly,
whoops, because some
people think it's fake.
But I don't ever want that.
I don't want there to ever
be a fake vibe at Verve.
It's not that.
We don't tell people
like, and then
make sure you put on your smile,
and get your flair badges.
It's not about that.
We tell people, just be
normal, just be real.
If you're not someone
who would smile or say,
hey, how's it going, to
someone who walks in and stands
in front of you, then,
OK, that's your world,
but maybe Verve is not
the right culture for you.
So we just try to find
friendly, outgoing people that
want to take care of you, and
tell them to just be normal.
KRISTI LEWIS: So I
guess, leaning into that,
we can go on the flip side
of that to your relationship
with your vendors, the people
who provide the coffee grounds.
You want to talk about
that a little bit?
COLBY BARR: Sure.
The grounds or--
KRISTI LEWIS: The grounds.
I'm sorry, the beans.
COLBY BARR: I'm just kidding.
People see our roaster
sometimes in Seabright,
in Santa Cruz, where
we have our roastery.
We've always created this
whole fishbowl effect
with our roastery.
It's very transparent, what we
do, and you can come see it.
And they always see these big
round drums, cylinders, rather.
And they say, oh, is that
where you grind the beans?
These giant grinders but,
they're our coffee roasters,
but anyway I'm just kidding.
Just kidding, Kristi.
KRISTI LEWIS: It's good.
You can call me out.
COLBY BARR: Yeah, for sure.
I mean, our sourcing program at
Verve, farm level, we call it,
does go full circle
for me, personally,
back to growing up on a
farm with a parent who was--
with parents, but my
dad would go into--
my mom growing up on a farm
herself, and then my dad
also growing up on a farm
and going to UC Davis,
it was really instilled--
and being really take
care of business people that
never did shortcuts, and just
kept the orchards and
vineyards meticulous all year
round, never had
garbage on the ground,
everything is just perfect,
and the fruit would show that.
They grew some of the best
sauvignon blanc in Paris,
anywhere in the world.
But they never really
got paid premiums for it.
They were just treated
as a commodity.
And it's like, kids
on laptops buying.
What's this?
How much is the price?
How much is it over here?
$0.04 cheaper per
pound over here.
Buy it here.
Send it to the grocer.
With no sense of, but what's
the difference in quality?
Who are these people?
What's their background?
Is there any value add we can--
it's just a commodity.
And coffee being one of
the more traded commodities
in the world, I mean,
for perspective,
how much coffee is out there.
Starbucks buys like 2 and
1/2% of the world's coffee.
So there's the other 97 and 1/2%
percent of the world's coffee
that's not being
sold by Starbucks.
That's how big the market is.
It's a commodity market.
And so, well, we got
into Verve, and wanting
to figure out how we could
do something different.
And the tipping point of
what became third wave coffee
was to go find the best
coffees in the world,
and that there was this new
world happening of discovery,
and just extraordinary
flavors coming
into the world of coffee.
And we sought to go find them.
So when we started
Verve for the first,
I'm not sure, six,
seven years, or so,
I was our only coffee buyer.
So I traveled like four
months out of the year
all around the globe--
Central America, South
America, East Africa--
for like four months
out of the year,
traveling to go find coffees,
meet producers, go back and see
those producers again,
discover new gems,
out position people on coffees,
and to really help find them,
but also to help be
part of what is maybe
the point of the spear of
a enormous global industry,
but to just help say,
we're willing to pay you
equitably for this
work you do, which
produces an extraordinarily
high quality product.
That same product
that we're then
going to take, and sell at
a higher premium than maybe
some people sell,
definitely compared
to what most people sell,
because there is a value there,
that's worth it.
And we think that--
I guess we're off
the rails here,
but I just fully
steered away from how
being nice to
producers, which we are.
But, no, to me
the economic lever
is the most important lever.
If you want to help a
farmer, pay them more.
You can go ask every
single one of our farmers,
and say, what do
you really need?
And they're just going
to say, just pay me more.
A lot of people think farmers--
it's like a pity
thing and all this.
And I hate that marketing.
I hate that kind of cause
marketing for coffee,
for producers.
Because, growing up on a
farm, my grandpa, so badass,
my dad, hard as nails.
Those are the last
people on Earth
that want your pity are farmers.
They just want to
be treated fairly,
and to feel like their
hard work is worth it.
They have enough stress
with Mother Nature
and a lot of other
things then to--
so we built our
business around that.
And it really starts
with customers
paying more for a cup of
coffee because there's
x amount of dollars
in a cup of coffee,
and then everyone
has their margins.
And I believe in supply chain.
I mean, you need--
someone's drinking the coffee.
Going back in time, someone's
delivering the coffee,
roasting the coffee, buying the
coffee, importing the coffee.
Someone exported the coffee.
Someone shipped it, and
insured it in between.
Someone milled the
coffee for export.
Right before that, somebody
processed the freshly
picked cherries.
And then someone
grew those cherries.
You need all of those steps.
I mean, people can be vertically
integrated or whatever.
But those steps don't go away.
I think it's cool if everyone
has a sustainable transparent
business model.
The middle man concept is that--
middle men, to
me, is a term tied
to people that operate
within a supply chain, that
take advantage of it
without transparency,
and exploit people on
either side of them.
But as far as steps in a supply
chain, everybody's critical.
And all through those
points of the supply chain,
we treat all of them with as
much respect, and honesty,
and transparency as we can.
Because at the other end of the
supply chain is the producer,
and at the other
end-- the bookmarks
are literally coffee
drinkers and coffee growers.
And they're the most
disconnected physically
and emotionally.
People that are growing coffee
on the hills in Santa Bárbara,
Honduras, totally can't
necessarily relate to people
who work at Google,
or maybe vice versa.
But those are the two
most important parts.
Everyone else is facilitating.
Yeah, you could
say we're curators.
We go find the stuff.
This is cool.
This is hot.
This is not.
But you need someone to throw
down money at the one end,
and you need someone to
be willing to produce
at the other end,
and those two need
to have a synergy
between the two.
So we work really hard
in our whole business
to create that bridge
and foster that economy.
AUDIENCE: So yeah, I was really
curious about that decision
to be in Santa Cruz, and
not one of the obvious
places that you were probably
thinking about being.
A lot of us here in
marketing or touch marketing,
and I would think you have
to go where the business is
or where the people would be.
How was marketing for you,
and getting your name out,
and getting going,
when maybe you
were thinking about just
surfers walking in for coffee.
It's not necessarily
someone that's going to--
I don't know, a business
person in the valley.
COLBY BARR: Yes, being where
the people are could have--
I mean, if we had opened in
San Francisco 10 years ago,
maybe we'd be even in a
different type of company,
as far as timing and everything.
But, for me, although
we were based
in Santa Cruz for some
personal reasons, Ryan and I,
our goal was never to be the
best coffee in Santa Cruz.
Our goal was to be the
best coffee in the world
and to create the best
coffee company in the world.
We just didn't know
if anyone was ever
going to even get it or care.
But that was our path was
I want our coffee to be--
our influences were my friends
out of Oslo, in Norway,
and just what's happening
in Australia, and Melbourne.
We were really wanting
to step up to that stage.
And I think it's because of
that, and the timing of when
we opened as super
early adopters,
that's kind of how
it all came together.
And then once we had those
little opportunities,
we had product that
stepped up to it.
I mean, one of our first places
our brand ever went from Santa
Cruz, like two months in,
was straight to the heart
of Manhattan with
Café Grumpy out there,
who at the time was
the east coast Ritual.
There's a lot more on
the east coast now,
but they were very early.
And someone came
through Santa Cruz,
and had our coffee
thought it was amazing,
brought a bag of Ethiopia Conga,
and brought it back to them.
And I remember, I
was working bar,
and I had to duck
down by the counter.
And I got a call from the
manager at Café Grumpy that
said, we want to feature you
on bar, here in Manhattan.
And then that's how Oliver
Strand from the New York Times
heard about us.
And then he wrote about it.
It just-- so it was
based on quality.
And I think the
idea that we were
trying to think
big, but even just
because that's what we wanted
out of the company personally.
And then that ended up working.
So I guess kind of like
secreting it a little bit.
And the brand is super
important, straight up,
design, brand, that
always matters to us.
How we want to
design our stores,
customer experience,
how we want to look,
what we think of
the brand-- we've
always really been into
brand and design as well.
So we always thought of that.
AUDIENCE: So it's kind
of a two part question,
but you mentioned that
when you were initially
picking your first location,
third wave coffee hadn't really
taken off yet, right?
And, obviously, in
the last 10 years,
there's been an
explosion of that,
especially in the Bay
Area, from Equator,
Four Barrel, et cetera.
The first question is, amongst
the other third wave players,
are there any that you
really admire, and why?
And the second piece of that is,
how you see Verve in relation
to some of the other
players in this space?
What, from your perspective,
really sets Verve apart
from the pack?
COLBY BARR: Sure,
yeah, I mean, well,
it's kind of split into two
groups really because a lot
of the people that
were our biggest--
a couple of people that were big
influences on us when we were
opening--
Stumptown, Intelligentsia--
Ryan, my business partner's
brother worked at the Blue
Bottle kiosk on Linden Street,
when that was all they had.
So we go back in that world.
Those were all influences on us.
And as you know,
there's been a lot
of business activity
with a lot of brands,
including those three brands.
So now that they're kind of
off the table in that regard,
with the M&A stuff
that's happened.
Looking to the other side of
things, what other brands are
out there that now influence
us, or that I think
are influential.
I mean, there's--
I mean, I see stuff all
the time on Instagram.
New brands following us, or
something, like, who's this?
I check it out.
I'm like, damn,
that's a killer logo.
That brand package,
that packaging is cool.
I like how they did this.
I see cold beverage drinks
being made and servingware,
and I'm like, that's hot.
I just see-- it's things
happening all the time here
and there.
But the major brands that
had a influence on us early,
just because you look up to
see like, well, who's doing it?
And who else is doing it?
And those were the
ones we looked up to,
so now we're kind of
on our own trajectory.
And how we feel
different, I mean,
I feel like we've always
had service first,
especially like, 10 years ago.
And that was super not cool in
the clichés of waxed mustaches,
and suspenders,
and all this stuff.
And rockstar baristas,
we were super anti that.
In fact, that's, actually, one
of the main reasons we never
opened in San Francisco, is
that we just didn't-- there was
an energy that was happening-- a
very young, young tense energy.
And we didn't want to really
get pulled into that world.
We wanted to just
go do our own thing.
And so I guess maybe
that's another way.
We've always just
done our own thing,
and worried about
what we're up to.
Totally influenced, and love
seeing what everyone's doing.
I'm super into
everything that happens.
But, at the end of the day, at
Verve, we just go our own path,
and be really nice
to people, really
focus on our retail environments
being more residential
than commercial, have wholesale
program that can step up
and really service
this level of business,
but still be down to earth.
We're putting a lot energy into
our online stuff right now.
And then we have some RTD and
some cool single serve stuff
that we're working on, for
new, innovative, next step
stuff with our company.
AUDIENCE: I drink
coffee, occasionally.
I don't really think about
what's in my cup too much.
Maybe everybody here knows
what it is, but I don't really
know much about
third wave coffee,
and what that movement means.
And was there a first
wave, a second wave?
Is there a fourth one?
COLBY BARR: They went ninth,
sixth, and then third.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I was
just kind of wondering,
if maybe you could find
more context on that,
and also maybe talk about
where you got your name from.
COLBY BARR: Yeah, absolutely.
Those are great questions
because, yeah, I mean,
the idea of first wave,
second wave, third wave
loosely is first wave is like
our grandparents' coffee--
institutional canned coffee,
Folgers, Yuban, Maxwell House,
sort of that
post-war era coffee--
which was really where
coffee got big in the US,
and really started the
real commercialization,
and commoditization of coffee.
Second wave, so that ran for
like 30 years or so, then
second wave comes about
with-- it basically
is the Starbucks revolution.
Howard Schultz creating--
going from just coffee
is this thing that you take
two scoops, put it in here,
mix with water, and
you have coffee.
Or it's like $0.25 diner
coffee, nickel diner coffee.
Into now, you step into espresso
culture, espresso drinks--
basically, espresso culture
for starters that Howard
brought from Europe
after visiting there.
And the idea of $4.00 coffee.
That concept of espresso
culture, $4.00 coffee,
and coffee houses as, he's
coined the term, third place.
You know, you have your work,
home, and this other place,
whether it's a
coffee shop or not.
But just this idea that
coffee isn't just this thing
your grandpa drinks
in the morning
before going out
and bailing hay.
It's like cool.
I'm going to like-- my mom does
it and meets her friends there.
So that is second wave.
And then third wave came as just
this next generation grew up--
everyone grows up on the
previous generation-- grew up
on Starbucks.
Not me, personally, because I
grew up in a super small town,
didn't have a Starbucks,
still doesn't.
But that what's next?
And that people started
finding these little--
lots of coffee that
tasted different.
The auction systems that in the
coffee world, the niche insider
world, started for the best
of Panama auctions, these cup
of excellence auctions, where
they started rewarding farmers
based on cup quality
blind, and having
auctions for their coffee.
There was a book written
called "God in a Cup"
that really was a turning point
to put third wave on the map.
And the Geisha
variety of coffee that
has been sort of synonymous
with the highest quality,
although that symbol is
definitely, it's getting
planted in a lot of places that
maybe that coffee shouldn't
grow, but where it
still grows the best,
a lot of places where
we get that coffee,
it's still one of the
best coffees in the world.
So those are those three phases.
So yeah, yeah, Grandpa's coffee,
Starbucks revolution, and then,
for lack of a better term, the
hipster coffee world that we
all think of as coffee now.
Although, I'm sure like, in
1975, if you were like, 20,
and you got coffee,
you thought you
were a hipster getting coffee
at the hipster coffee shop.
So those are those three eras.
And then a lot of people
ask, what's fourth wave?
People are ready to jump
to fourth wave right now.
And I've heard fourth
way is cold brew.
Fourth wave is this.
Fourth wave is convenience.
Fourth wave is bringing
food into your cafés,
like we've brought a lot of
more Melbourne sort of concepts
into our store-- avocado
toast, things like that.
I don't know.
I think, to me, that's still
an extrapolation of third wave.
Fourth wave, probably,
shouldn't really
come for another 10
or 15 years per the,
unless we're kind of on
geometric sort of growth plan
here.
Yeah, and then we
got our name Verve.
It originally came because it's
a record label, Verve Records.
It's a jazz label.
And we were just trying
to think of names.
We had a million names.
And Ryan, because we
both play music and jazz,
said, what about Verve?
And it kind of just stuck.
And we looked it up,
and it was available,
and sat with it for a while.
And we ended up calling
ourselves that so.
But it means the spirit
and enthusiasm surrounding
the creation of art.
And so once we saw
the definition,
I was like, damn, that
really feels right.
It's like passion, energy.
If you have a lot of Verve,
maybe that's the energy you
feel when you come
into a Verve café.
People behind the bar, it's
trying to just be posi.
AUDIENCE: I was going to also
ask you how you got your name,
so that was an easy one.
So I'm going to totally pivot
and ask you a tough one.
Thanks for coming, by the way.
Just thinking about, coffee
has this very specific kind
of climate that it
grows in, and you see it
in equatorial regions.
And I think,
anecdotally, it seems
like a lot of those regions are
also areas of high conflict.
You look at Central America,
or Yemen, parts of Africa.
What's our role in all of that?
And we're so separated
from the growers,
just because of the nature
of how coffee grows,
and where we are
physically, do you
have a role in that,
for good or for bad?
Do you have a point
of view on how
our collective hunger for
coffee is hopefully making lives
better?
COLBY BARR: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I don't work for the CIA.
And I just watched,
I'm totally up
to speed on "Narcos," so, yeah,
I can answer this question.
I mean, you're right.
I mean, Latin America--
I mentioned "Narcos"
because that's--
I mean, you hear
about this-- when
you travel to all
these countries,
you hear about the history
of a lot of things that back
in the day felt conspiratorial.
And then you're like,
oh, yeah, but then you
just hear it first hand.
That's another talk probably
but with US involvement,
obviously, I'm not a
Latin American studies,
but I'm sure there's people who
could school me all up on that,
but it's tough.
I mean, there are certain
places that we don't buy coffee
from because it's
so complicated,
one, to travel there, like I
can't go to Yemen right now.
I mean, I've been to
Rwanda, and Burundi,
and I've been in Kenya,
in parts of Ethiopia,
and all places in Colombia.
It can get really real down
there in southern Colombia.
And there are certain
places, in Colombia,
I can't go and be
there overnight.
You can't even really
go during the daytime,
but we go to a lot of out
there places in Colombia.
But to answer your
question, I see coffee
as a lever for change.
And I see that lever really
saying the word quality on it.
And that's the coffee
lever that we move.
And, to me, I just
really believe that--
not like what we do is
so important, like Verve.
I mean, we're just a small
sliver, but all we can do
is what we can do.
And we want to do it
clearly and loudly.
And that is to
just say that we--
that's part of the reason we
travel to go meet producers,
is to understand who they
are, and to understand
how our approach can help them,
again, not out of charity.
Farmers don't want your charity.
They just want to
be treated fairly.
So I think one of the
best things you can do
is just help create,
for any farming family,
is help create a stable
economy, and something
that they can count on.
And if you find producers
that have a good address,
their farm is in a
good spot, and they're
willing to put in
this extra work
because they're
passionate about it.
You see it all the time.
The best farmers are the
most passionate ones.
There is ones that get
lucky, but not really.
You do need to
have a good site--
this side of the
hill, this elevation,
this type of microclimate, this
aspect, this soil, all this.
But really it comes down to, the
farmer's passion and hard work.
And I do feel
like, what we do in
that way is good because
it opens up opportunities
for people to have
more opportunities,
and more decision-making
authority in how they live.
But it's super complex, I mean,
East Africa, Yemen, come on.
I mean, Kenya, even, and
then all of Latin America
is mostly--
it's really simmered down a lot.
But then with
everything happening
with the cartel and stuff like
that, it's it's own thing.
But we try to steer
clear of it, and just
do what we can to
empower farmers.
AUDIENCE: I wonder about this
notion of paying for quality,
and a lot of the talk about
the progression of coffee,
and how it's viewed.
Is there anything else,
or any other industries,
or within the food
space, even, where
you see an opportunity for
that transition to happen?
Where people have expectations
of paying very little
for something, where
you can see bringing
either higher quality
options, or higher quality
brands with also that
higher price tag?
COLBY BARR: I mean, it's
probably in everything
to be honest with you.
I mean, part of it is
what industries globally
are available for that.
And part of it is how we
nationally think about food.
So I can't remember
the statistic off hand,
but I've said it before.
But the percentage
Americans spend on food
is really low in the
developing world.
It's like, don't
hold me to this,
but it's something
like a quarter, what
a lot of people in France
or Italy spend on food.
So part of it is just a desens--
a desensitizing, a desensity?
What am I trying to say here?
You know what I'm saying.
We are desensitized on
the price of food because
of a lot of reasons, including
subsidies, and corn, and things
like that.
And we see that as the
value add is cheaper,
is better, and bigger is better,
not this room, necessarily,
but that's just this thing
that's been kind of drilled,
for good reasons
because how people think
about food security is one of
the best ways to grow a nation.
So I think you could
look at almost anything
and think, well, what
is the version of this
that helps create change?
Who is in this supply chain
that wants to do better?
And who's already wants to
produce something better,
and how do we help
them have a voice?
I mean, you could do, I
mean, like [INAUDIBLE] tea.
I mean, tea has
done really amazing.
I mean, really, really amazing
tea growers in China and Japan,
can get paid really great
prices for their tea.
I mean, you could
pick any commodity,
and dissect it, and
try to find out,
how we could leverage
the people that
want to do quality
because on one end,
I believe it's us
helping producers.
But I also think there's
just a huge audience that
just wants better stuff.
There's a huge audience
of people that just like,
I'd pay $0.50 more for
blackberries if they always
tasted amazing, or strawberries.
Or I mean, you could just pick
anything you eat, any fruit,
and say, would you be willing
to pay $0.50 more because that
could be like a 20%, 30%
increase in the price.
It can be applied
almost anywhere.
We choose just to be
focused on coffee.
But I do think about that
a lot in that there's
an audience that wants
quality, and they
want to have this better
experience in their life.
And they're willing
to pay for it.
And there's people that
want to produce that.
And it's just connecting those
two into the supply chain
because without them--
without people producing
high quality anything,
there's no product
for people to buy.
And without people willing
to step up and pay premiums
for quality experiences,
then there's
no livelihood or reason
for people to do it.
And I believe,
fundamentally, both
of these two ends
of the spectrum
exist in almost
everything we touch.
It's just a matter
of connecting them.
And that's what we
try to do in coffee.
KRISTI LEWIS: Great, well,
thank you so much for coming.
COLBY BARR: Cool.
KRISTI LEWIS: Thank
you all for coming.
COLBY BARR: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[? Thank you. ?]